at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking I'm a cybernetic organism living
tissue over metal endoskeleton thank you
for supporting the sponsors of this show
99designs
which is your one-stop shop for all
things graphic design related go to
99designs comm forward slash tim to see
the projects that I've put up including
the mock-ups and drafts of the book
cover for the 4-hour body ex-officio
ex-officio and I go way back
ex-officio dot-com forward slash Tim you
can see the clothing that I've used for
traveling through 20 plus countries
including the underwear by the way
that's about half of my underwear drawer
right now ex officio com forward slash
Tim you can also see the viral video
that I put out which shows you how to
travel the world with ten pounds or less
as always you can subscribe to this
podcast on iTunes and you can find all
of the links and resources from this
episode as well as every other episode
by going through 4-hour workweek comm
forward slash podcast spell it all out
or you can go to 4-hour workweek comm
and just click on podcast feedback if
you have feedback I would love your
thoughts anything at all who you'd like
to see on this show ping me on Twitter
at Steffes that's Twitter comm /tf ER
Riss or on facebook at facebook.com
forward slash Tim Ferriss with two R's
and two S's
hello ladies and gentlemans tim ferriss
again the Tim Ferriss show for those of
you who are new to the show this is
where I try to dissect excellence
whether that is a billionaire investor a
chess prodigy an entrepreneur or
otherwise how do they do what they do
what are the tools and tricks and
tactics that they use that you can use
as well and in this episode I try to
dissect the mind of Nick Ganju who who
I've known for a very very long time
since graduating from college basically
he is the CTO of ZocDoc
and has raised more than ninety five
million dollars in venture capital as of
june 2003 or so and they have more than
6 million users per month and although
Nick would hate for me to describe it
this way imagine opentable for doctors
although it fixes much more than that
many other broken aspects of quality
health care and in this episode we geek
out on math which I am phobic of I've
had a lifetime fear of mathematics so we
geek out on how to tackle numeracy if
you're not comfortable with math poker
ping-pong how to write a hit song and
the philosophical implications of Moss
off Monsters Inc one of my favorite
movies certainly among many other things
it is not too dense that's the whole
idea to try to demystify and disarm
things that are intimidating and Nick
has just an incredible capacity for
simplifying what is what appears to be
the very very difficult so I had a blast
with this I hope you do as well so
please meet Nick Ganju
hello everybody this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode in addition
of the Tim Ferriss show today is a rare
treat because I have an old friend of
mine who's got all sorts of dirt on me
and knows all the skeletons in the
closet Nick Ganju Nick how are you I'm
great how are you doing I'm doing very
well and you're in New York City at the
moment yeah that's right I mean I'm in
had so the the beginning I suppose goes
back some ways we initially met it must
have been in 2000 is that right yeah I
think so I think you were looking for an
apartment and and I had an extra bedroom
that I was renting uh and I if I
remember correctly I didn't make the cut
this was this was at the height of the
dot-com boom at at at a point where I
suppose was right at the top of the
roller coaster in a lot of ways and
housing was just next to impossible not
unlike what it's like right now and I
guess it must it must have been
Craigslist casual encounters or I'm
Canada the rental section and we met up
and didn't end up becoming roommates but
ended up becoming friends and playing a
lot of pool and is it was amusing to me
to read your official bio for the first
time yesterday to try to get some of the
additional contacts see you ended up
being the bay area billiards champion is
this right yeah it was like a one of
those leagues that you you join and
ended up being the champion that year I
played a lot of pool in college and then
since we were both just out of college I
I had a you know still retained all that
skill if you play me right now I'd
probably be really really and the we're
gonna dig into some of the other very
varied eclectic sort of dos equis skills
that you got that you seem to have like
table tennis and sort of deconstruct why
that is also get into the music but for
those people who aren't familiar with
you and we can certainly get into the
professional stuff but where did you
where did you grow up
what did your parents do it maybe you
can give us some background
sure sure I grew up in Chicago in the
West suburbs of Chicago my parents were
both doctors so you know
nice nice comfortable sort of upbringing
I was very fortunate in that way
I went to undergrad majored in computer
science finished in 1998 worked in
Austin Texas at a company called trilogy
for a year but then decided that the you
know the comm boom of the time was just
way too hot for me to be working at a
larger company so you know like all day
all the gold hunters of history I moved
out west it's a California you know
further for the Gold Rush of 1999 I
guess you could call it and you know in
tried my luck at a couple startups there
and you you ended up then I suppose
bringing us to the to the current day
co-founding ZocDoc and the what is the
current state of Zac how many employees
do you have maybe you can give us some
stats yeah sure
we are currently about 500 and 600
employees and over 6 million people
visit ZocDoc each month to search for a
doctor and you know to give a little
background
itzhak doc is a site where you can come
you can search for a doctor and you can
see reviews you can see photos and you
can book an employment right online so
in the way that you can book everything
else online these days we're trying to
bring doctor appointment booking online
now for those people who haven't used
this site would it be fair to just as an
imperfect analogy say that it's similar
to it's a more refined OpenTable plus a
bunch of other extra benefits for
doctors that it has that sort of ease of
use or more yes certainly certainly it
has that OpenTable aspect where you can
book appointments online of course it
also has the Yelp aspect where you can
see reviews and you can see photos and
you can also now check-in which means
you can fill out your medical history
forms
online before you get to the doctor's
office so that medical form is now
prefilled and you know as as you visit
subsequent doctors you don't have to
refill a medical form so we're you know
we're slowly adding more and more
features that make you know that process
as painless as possible
so the one of the one of the topics that
I wanted to talk about comes to mind
that when I call to my memory the first
visit to the ZocDoc offices and we we've
we've spent a lot of time together we've
had plenty of work together played a lot
of pool together and I've always been
fascinated by your your ability to not
just test assumptions but also cut
through a lot of the fuzzy thinking to
hard numbers and analytics and the
displays that you had at ZocDoc
the the real-time displays of numbers
and metrics I think we're a great sort
of external representation for me of
your mind and many people probably do
not know that one of the reasons I went
to I chose to go to Princeton undergrad
which by the way those people who are
listening who might be applying to
colleges I was told by my guidance
counselor I would not get into I talked
about encouragement and and I think this
is actually going to be relevant to our
conversation later you have to look at
incentives because it economics
ultimately is a study of incentives and
how people respond to them and what
guidance counselors even at very good
schools want to be able to say is 90
percent of my students got into their
first choice the easiest way to do that
is to make sure that their first choices
are media so that but the one of the
draws for Princeton was it was one of
the few schools in in the the top group
I was considering that did not have a
math requirement and I had a horrible
experience in tenth grade with a math
teacher
and this might seem strange to folks but
a she was a female math teacher who I
think had just been really put through
the ringer to get to where she was and
she was really really kind of
belligerent towards a handful of boys in
the class and they turned me off to math
completely from that point forward
in contrast my brother had the exact
opposite experience in tenth grade had a
wonderful teacher and he went on to
major in math and get a you know pursue
a PhD in statistics so I'd be curious to
hear sort of the origins of your
interest in computer science and and and
also sort of your general thinking on
these types of skills I know that's
broad but a lot of people like myself
feared that it's it's something innate
it's completely innate you either have
it or you don't
so maybe you could sort of rewind the
clock and and talk about your experience
with getting comfortable with this type
of thing yeah sure
so in terms of the computer science you
know I started the way that many
computer nerds start which is I started
programming at an early age like nine or
ten years old on my Apple to see and
just trying to make games right like we
had those we had those games you know we
had the Atari 2600 and we had had some
simple games on my Apple and you know I
was like I want to try to do this so I
you know I bought a book on basic
programming and I tried to make a couple
games I tried to reproduce the game from
wargames that if you remember that oh
sure of course yeah with Matt Broderick
so I tried to make I tried to
reconstruct that game which is the game
and in that movie is it's called global
thermonuclear war and it's a pretty
violent game and III tried to recreate
it with my nine-year-old you know brain
trying to deconstruct weird I'd like to
employ nuclear missiles and I actually
as actually working on it at school in
grade school and my my principal walked
into the computer lab and I got in big
trouble because I was I was making a
game called global thermonuclear war so
but you know but that was like the
genesis of my my interest and then in in
in high school we had these programmable
calculators and I and I started writing
games
a calculator and giving it to all my
friends you know in in the way that
misguided nerds are you know I had at
age 15 I thought I thought I would get a
lot of girls this way and it turns out
that writing you know Tetris on your
calculator does not actually win you the
cheerleaders but that was you know that
was that was my best strategy at that
time suffice to say I was out single for
high school you know but then you know
and so my guidance counselor kind of saw
these kind of things too and recommended
to me that I you know that I go in and
major in computer engineering or
computer science and that was something
that was not even really apparent to me
that that that was a whole major and
stuff and of course this is in the 90s
and you couldn't just google things and
so just information it was almost like
you know a revelation to me that you
could just go and do this as a as a
profession and you know and there's like
actually a formal training like you can
actually go to a four-year college and
get and get a computer science degree so
that was great and so I you know I went
to University of Illinois which is which
is like a sort of a top five computer
science school that kind of kind of
flirts in and out of there some years
it's number four and some years it's
number seven or whatever it's up to you
didn't Marc Andreessen develop mosaic
there yeah yeah and reasons from there
Max Levchin from PayPal's from there you
know a bunch of sort of illustrious
current you know Silicon Valley moguls
are from there so yeah it's a good
school and I you know I certainly really
really fell in love with computer
science when I when I did those four
years and kind of knew that I that's
what I wanted to do as a profession what
what made you fall in love with it there
and what do you think makes it a good
what makes it a top-five program aside
from maybe the selection bias and having
really good applicants over time start
to selected yeah that's you know
certainly every school has that sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy when you start
to get that you gain traction and all
the best kids want to go to your school
but I think that they are very vigilant
about keeping
the computer science curriculum current
and so you can see and I had I had a you
know I had a couple friends that had
gone to different schools at that time
and also majored in computer science and
you know I was learning Java at the time
which was the hot new thing this is like
nineteen nineteen ninety six or
something and and and you know there
were we already had courses in Java and
my friends were still learning stuff in
C and so you know I think that the the
new tools are are the best schools are
very diligent about keeping the the
curriculum up-to-date especially in
computer science as we all know the the
industry and the technologies change so
quickly and in a world where that's
changing so quickly I think this is part
of what's so intimidating to a lot of
folks whether they're just trying to get
by and want to be employable or they are
hoping to invest in technology companies
which is a very dangerous game to play I
think for a lot of reasons but the how
much past a certain point because I I
recognize for instance it's easy for me
to look at learning natural languages
which I assume does bad at learning up
until fifteen or sixteen and I can
destroy a lot of myths and old wives
tales about that so when someone says to
me oh my god I'm too old to learn a
language it would take me my entire
lifetime takes decades to become fluent
bla bla I can I can very easily
dismantle those and get people excited
about learning a language even if
they're you know thirty forty whatever
it might be
with computer science and math I have a
lot of insecurities and you know I can
do very basic stuff but never to
calculus you know got up to pre Cal and
how is how coachable are these things
and and how valuable is it to try to
become more comfortable with sort of the
quantified side of life at a delay at a
later point right I just turned thirty
seven it's it's one of these things that
dogs me as an insecurity is much in a
way that not being able to swim dogged
me for in
till I was 30 yeah but maybe you could
maybe comment on that
sure sure I think you know there's
certain fields of math that are
extremely important and just become more
and more relevant every day and you see
like this kind of you know like the big
data sort of I hate to use buzzwords but
that you know that sort of trend that
that is you know has come into favor in
the last few years which is a very real
thing
despite the buzzwords you know there's a
lot of sort of information to be gleaned
and improvements in our society to be
had from from you know from statistical
analysis so you know statistics and
probability and statistics are things
that are just gonna become bigger and
bigger parts of our of our world you
know in terms of calculus I don't think
I think if anything calculus is sort of
diminishing because that that sort of
that sort of field of math was more
applicable when you when you didn't have
a giant computer on every desktop you
know giant in terms of you know
processing power to crunch the crap out
of out of numbers and a lot of things
that were I'm trying to make it like
layman's a lot of things that were
closed form solutions which means you
know they got solved through these sort
of complex equations that you see with
you know lots of weird symbols in them
now how computers can just sort of brute
force crank out the answers to them and
and and in a better way too because it's
sort of you can you can more closely
mirror reality with a computer than you
can with a closed-form solution like a
calculus equation and so and so I don't
think you know it's it's not a big deal
if most people don't know calculus but
there's there's there's fields of math
which are certainly helpful in
understanding what would what would
those areas be and I suppose just to
jump right into it you know if you were
and this this conversation is inspired
for those people listening partially
because we sat down at the ZocDoc
offices to talk about encryption and I
remember I was I would become really
fascinated by encryption and ciphers and
code breaking because of a science
fiction I suppose you could call a
science fiction book
called Krypton nomicon and so we started
talking about encryption and you got up
and and walked me through the basic
principles of encryption and feel free
to correct me or provide some details if
I'm missing them but as it applies in a
lot of computer science then we went out
to dinner that night and sat down with a
bunch of really impressive CTS and guys
who've been via piece of engineering and
we talked about encryption and it just
blew my mind that something that I felt
so utterly out of my depth with a few
hours earlier I was able to actually
cogently listen to discourse about in a
few hours and that really encouraged me
but it's been hard for me to determine
how how do I walk out and I mean I know
you're a good friend of mine but you're
so busy so I don't want you to be my my
pro bono you know like a mental model
mentor yeah so how should somebody do
how should somebody in it in a fun or
interesting way develop some of these
skills right because I you look at this
and this is such a simple thing that it
kind of blew my mind when the
probabilities if we look at
probabilities humans are so bad sort of
intrinsically it seems at working with
probabilities and if you have let's say
a birth if you have a big party and
people bump into each other and they
have the same birthday party you know
our birthday date they're sort of
astonished right they're like oh my god
what are the chances it's like one in a
million and I just and I'm just looking
at this description here on Wikipedia of
the the birthday problem and the
birthday paradox
and you know the probability obviously
reaches a hundred when the number of
people reaches three hundred sixty-seven
because there are you know that were we
extrapolate from 365 days a year but you
get to 50% probability with just 23
people and yes just it's so hard for
people to grasp that so well to be well
let me refine it a little bit to be to
state it really precisely it's not the
one of those people one of those 23
people could go and ask the other 22 and
would find the same birthday right it's
that any two of those 23 people have the
same birthday does that make sense yeah
it's a little bits a little bit
different but it actually I think that's
where the the misconception comes in is
that you know you kind of take from it
like wow if I walked around and asked 22
people like there's a 50% chance that
that I'd have the same birthday as one
of them which is not the right then not
the right way to think about it right
and the Devils in the details right with
those subtleties I mean massive
miscalculations even by very smart
experienced people right you look at
something like long-term capital
management right they build this massive
lead sophisticated system that doesn't
take into account that somebody else
could have a similar machine that would
then sort of trigger this crazy
back-and-forth that would end in
catastrophe right so yeah if somebody
feels as I do right that they they want
to be more comfortable with this type of
thing but they're not are there any
particular approaches or books or
anything like that that you would
recommend yeah I think I think that
people get intimidated because they you
know they sort of look online and
Wikipedia especially does this you go
and you're like what is expected value
or something and you look at it and
Wikipedia immediately like gives you
these Greek symbols yeah on the first
and everyone's seen that right like the
first paragraph is really the first line
if the problem exactly and it's like you
know and that serves the you know that
even intimidates me and I you know I
think I know a fair bit about math but
like it you know the best way to do it
is to just start really simple and then
work your way up slowly and so you know
when you want to talk about probability
like you know let's play a game
you and me right let's play a game where
we roll a die a six-sided die right and
and if if the number becomes six if the
number is six I pay you a dollar and
then it over is one through five you pay
me a dollar right now would you play
that game no not play that game
right so you wouldn't play that game and
so it you know it's it's intuition right
now now let's let's change the game and
say that if if if a six comes up I pay
you a thousand dollars and if one
through five each come up
you have to pay me at $1 yes I'll put
again right so you play that game right
so now the question is at which point at
what points should you play or play it
not or not play it right would you play
it at $3 like a very Shakespearean play
yes if the player not to play you know
if the six was $3 if I paid you $3 when
a six showed up you know would you play
that game right probably not yeah I have
to start doing calculations right the
genesis of all math really is is you
starting from these common sense or
these railroad problems and saying okay
well you know how do I understand this
problem you know my intuition says I I
wouldn't play it if I only want a dollar
when I hit six and I would play it if I
won $1,000 when I played six you know
wouldn't would I do it at $10 what I do
it at $3 and and you know the so you
know start to start from there and you
know we can walk through this problem
right let's say little bit a simple way
to think about this problem is let's
assume in six roles you get one of each
right like let's say we roll it six
times and you get 1 1 1 2 1 3 1 4 1 5
and 1/6 mm-hmm so you know for the $3
it's it's right you you would lose $5
for each of one through five mm-hmm
right and then you would win $3 when you
rolled a six mm-hmm right so you would
make $3 and you would lose $5 so you'd
be at negative 2 $2 yeah right and so
you know so you can start to see you at
which point you would break even which
is five I'll cheat and give you the
answer but you know at five dollars you
break-even exactly right if I paid you
$5.00 every time a six showed up right
then you would lose $5 for each dealer
rules and that and then you would win $5
when you got the six I'm trying to I'm
tracking you so far I'm not as dumb as
I'm like I really I'm a bit dumber than
I looked at that story but then that's
the genesis of it right so now let's
roll to die yeah right and like what are
the odds of getting you know two sixes
right so the odds are that you know each
one has a one in six chance
of getting a six each die has a one in
six chance of getting a six and you
multiply those together in the odds of
getting two sixes there's one in 37 36
yeah yeah and so now right so now you
now you can do the game again right
would I pay you how much did I pay you
if you get a 36 all right how much did I
pay you if you get to six as I should
say and and it just goes from there
right it just gets more and more complex
so right and then you're like blackjack
then is this is just more of the same
thing yeah right it's just a more
complex version of the same thing and so
you know if you start simple and
understand the the conceptual
underpinnings you know and then just
work your way up from there I think that
sort of every field of math can just be
can just be broken down that way you
just start simple and not not get
intimidated by all these Greek symbols
now the the one of the things that
sparked my interest in exploring some of
this was my experience in television
when I was doing filming the Tim Ferriss
experiment which the future of which is
TBD for those people listening and
wondering it's the entire division at
Turner that produced it was fired
basically shut down and it's sitting on
a shelf so I am I've been battling to
try to rescue that for months suffice to
say keep an eye out I may need some
public support to get that done but the
the episodes included at one point going
to Vegas and being trained by a really
fascinating guy named Phil Gordon who
has a CS background who's taken home
millions of dollars in in winnings as a
professional poker player and he had a
week to train me to go heads up you know
one-on-one against professional poker
players and so you can imagine that week
was a lot of this type of conversation
and he would ask me these very very
basic probability questions and I just
have this like like stoned Labrador
Retriever
response with no words coming out of my
face and you just feel like you're
kidding me right
but work up to the point where he was
able to give me matrices for deciding in
a very binary way like
you you folder do you raise right and
then it started it I started memorizing
these sets of rules and it made it fun
right it gave it a context so that I
wasn't grappling with some of these
questions in a vacuum the the what what
are and I know one of the books you
recommended to me was how to measure
anything and some of it I found very
interesting and of course when we were
not too long ago sort of sitting and
hanging out at the pool and and
brainstorming stuff like this and
talking about investing you know you
were able to throw an extra element into
the conversation which was well you know
if you have a 30% probability of doing X
or 70% probability of doing Y yeah if
the person giving you that information
only tells the truth you know sixty
percent of the time then then what right
like how does that affect the outcomes
right are there any other books or even
just games or or methods for making this
a fun process for people right because
the the idea that I could spend a week
learning poker and be able to play with
without getting my total face ripped off
yeah so you know probably 70% of the
recreational players out there pretty
deadly yes huge ROI right that's that's
massive yeah that's great
what else what else comes to mind what
other books would you recommend to
people or resources yeah I love poker as
well I think poker is a great example of
math of a combination of math and like
sort of emotional intelligence also
coming into play but you know poker is a
great sort of reflection of all the
stuff we've been talking about of course
the you know the books I've recently
read a great book which is called how
not to be wrong the power of
mathematical thinking and this book by a
guy named Jordan elenberg is is a is it
is exactly what we're talking about it
it's like it's written for an audience
of people that have you know
historically
intimidated by math or just thought gee
I'm not good at math and introduces
things in a very simple way and then
works up to more complex concepts in the
way that we just broke down you know
probability with this dice game and so
that's a great book and I and I hope it
does well and I hope it it alleviates
some of this sort of you know the that
intimidation that people have in and
does this III know that we also chatted
at one point about your classes I there
might be a better term for them but
internally at at ZocDoc
trying to help you know poor poor
liberal arts majors like me become
better at goal-setting and things along
those lines so I I know you're a fan of
what is often referred to as SMART goals
would you mind talking about how you set
goals or how you suggest people set
goals and common problems with or common
mistakes that people make yeah sure I
mean I think that you know the easiest
example is that people so smart goals
means you know specific measurable
attainable realistic and timely and and
so right it's sort of a framework to
help you pick goals that eat that are
you can objectively hit or miss so
measurable means I'm going to you know
I'm going to do I'm going to lose
exactly ten pounds or you know at least
ten pounds in the next two months or
three months and you know and then you
can objectively decide at the end
whether or not you've lost ten pounds
right as opposed to saying I'm just
gonna lose weight and then you don't you
don't really know whether you know what
kind of goal and you don't it doesn't
work psychologically right you're just
like I'm just sort of vaguely losing
weight and you know putting that writing
down that goal literally putting it on
wall actually gives you something to
strive towards but then the next problem
after that so the first problem is just
setting objective goals right instead of
just saying let's try to accomplish X
all right let's try to get X more like
let's just try to get more people using
ZocDoc right as opposed to let's get 10
million more people to use TalkTalk are
different goals just just
psychologically speaking and then you
know in
and then at review time it's it's a it's
easy to see whether you did it or not
but then the next problem after that is
that you know people just say yeah that
sounds like a good number let's get a
million more people to use it or
whatever and but there's no basis in and
how they're gonna get to that million
right and so you know in the analogy I
like to use is you know when they tried
to put the first man in space or the
first man on the moon
you know that they didn't just say like
okay let's get in the rocket and like
burn the rocket as hard as we can and
maybe we'll get into space right they
they did all the math behind it right
they were like gravity pulls us this
much and we you know we have to take
this much weight up and so that I mean
this much fuel put this much fuel then
adds this much weight also to the to the
rocket so so that causes its own set of
problems and then there's wind
resistance and everything right and they
did all the math to figure out how to
get themselves into space but I feel
like in business and in life people just
say you know I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna add this much or I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna create this much more X
percent more of whatever is going to
happen and they haven't really done the
underlying math right everything I think
I'm guilty of that too definitely
because here you're constantly told as a
is a non quant comfortable person like
you gotta think big and spew like okay
great like I'm gonna build a billion
dollar company and then yeah that's a
good example right like if you if you
want to build a billion dollar company
what do you what do you need to do like
right what kind of revenue do you need
to to justify or what kind of earnings
do you need to justify being a billion
dollars and then you know what sort of
markets or what sort of opportunities
are available to that would create that
much earnings and then how are you gonna
get there right you can't just say like
let's just build a billion dollar
company and so I mean it's good to have
that goal but then you need a plan to
execute as well and I think that you
know one of the big improvements that
that we've done operationally is is you
know what I call business cases and what
it's what it's the math of how you're
gonna get there right and the example I
use which was sort of just a fun example
was was use that Monsters Inc
monsters are occurring is a recurring
kind of theme at our at ZocDoc so like
the the monsters for monsters inc I'm
blanking on their names now but those
characters from that movie I want to
call one of them Elmo but it's not the
right name it's lookout Mike Michael
Kowski or something man I can't believe
I'm blanking sounds good it's Ollie it's
Sully and then Michael County or
something anyway right so you know you
know and any team member that that
crushes it that week we give them one of
the stuffed animals and they're the
monster of the week and stuff so it's
this sort of recurring theme but you
know one of the my example that I used
was they have right they had these doors
to children's bedrooms where they they
go and they like make them either these
to scare them but now they make them
laugh or whatever James Michener is
Sully Sullivan and Mike Wazowski Mike
Wazowski yeah that was pretty close yeah
so you know so so they go into these
children's bedrooms and they make them
laugh and and that generates electricity
for the for the for the city that they
live in Monstropolis which is the name
of the city and so right like let's say
you know one day they're like short on
electricity and so the first thing right
like the first that like so then the CEO
of Monstropolis or CEO of monsters inc
is like let's generate more electricity
and then a bad you know a bad way to do
it be like let's just try to generate
more right and a good way to do it be
like let's generate one more like one
gigawatt more right and then it's like
okay one gigawatt great how do we get
there right and then well okay so each
store generates you know a megawatt you
know each door that you you manufacture
to a new child's bedroom like generates
one megawatt and so you need to generate
a thousand more doors like you need to
like manufacture a thousand more doors
to get to get this one gigawatt and then
and then so then how do you make a
thousand more doors well you need like a
hundred door manufacturers that each
make ten and then you try to do that but
then you realize there's like a 10
percent defect rate right and so it's
it's it's like sort of building up from
there and and understanding the math
behind it and then understanding if
that's realistic can I have you know 100
door makers or whatever
whatever I just said you know is it
realistic to hire that many that quickly
in one month or whatever but really
breaking down the plan to you know and
multiplying these numbers through to get
to the goal is really the difference
there between success and failure and
you know it's not complicated math right
it's just it's just you know I need a
thousand or so I need I need you know
100 door manufacturers that can each
make ten doors in a month and then I'll
have a thousand doors and so none of its
you know calculus or any of this other
stuff but it is you know rigorous in
terms of you know you have to be able to
those those those individual break it
down to the individual components those
things have to be executable right can I
actually get a hundred door makers and
does it each of them actually make ten
doors a month and etc and the how do you
then translate that to say weekly
check-ins more monthly check-ins how do
how do you how do people who take who do
this case study who've set a
quantifiable objectively measurable goal
but then ensure that they are on track
or at least check-in to see if they're
on track or not how frequently is that
done and and how do people improve the
odds of hitting those goals once they've
set it down on paper and taken say sort
of getting they have if they've accepted
and agreed that yes we need to
understand sort of the the the different
numbers that underpin this goal and the
assessments were making okay how do they
then how do you encourage them to keep
on track how often are they checking in
or having someone else check in on them
how does that work yeah sure so so
they're the goals are set quarterly so
every three months they have you know
they set this goal so so for going back
to this Monsters Inc example that would
be a 3-month goal would be the you know
we're gonna generate one more one extra
gigawatt of power and then they have to
write and then each week they're going
to follow the numbers that that you know
that were the break
this plant so they say you know how many
how many door manufacturers that I
actually hired this week and how many
doors did they actually manufacture this
week
right and then right and then you start
to get confidence around those don't
burst right you you start to see oh crap
I can't I can't hire a hundred door
makers in a month it's actually gonna
take me to three months to hire a
hundred but I can hire thirty in the
first month and they're each gonna
contribute ten doors so I'll at least
have three hundred doors in the first
month or whatever right and they you
learn something new you learn that that
that oh ten percent of the doors are
defective that's actually not three
hundred doors generated in the first
month it's two hundred and seventy doors
generate in the first month and so then
you add a new line and you're in your in
your business case here that you know is
going to subtract ten percent from your
finished product of doors and overtime
overtime you you you you generate a
really solid understanding of that game
of that of whichever whichever
initiative it is that you're planning as
you add lines and as you refine the
numbers free for each each line and then
so basically you start to fill in the
actuals and you look at their deviation
from your you know from your projections
when you start yeah from your base
assumptions which is something that you
know I'm I'm constantly astonished and I
do this in a very Fred Flinstone sort of
knuckle-dragging kind of way but I if I
look at just as a group for instance
investors angel investors or people who
are doing early-stage investments but
they form a thesis they go out and raise
a bunch of money and then they never
modify you know yes it's kind of like
the parody of george w bush that Stephen
Colbert did at one point where he gave
an address at like the Republican
National Convention or something and he
says you know I love you know I
paraphrase IV asleep he's like I stand
behind the president who no matter what
happens on Wednesday he still holds the
same belief on Thursday that he did in
Tuesday because they branded they
planted John Kerry is a flip-flopper and
and it's like it's sort of the mark of
intelligence to learn from your mistakes
and change your attitudes of thing and
so they were they were they were sort of
there was was ribbing which for for you
know for brand and carries a
flip-flopper yeah I'm not sure the yeah
that worked out exactly as I expected
yeah that's when you were a kid just due
to really not entirely shift gears
because it's closely related actually
before I go there do you have all of
your employees trained on excels is that
is that what that means when they're in
putting these values yeah think I'd look
likely update yeah this is done in Excel
each column is a month and so you can
see the time progressing you know going
to the right and then each row will be
one of these things so like you know
again with this Monsters Inc it's how
many how many door manufacturers I have
how many do they make in a month what's
the defect rate etc and then as a month
like turns into reality you you feel you
you overwrite the projected assumptions
with the with the actuals but it what I
think in general like what I'm saying
sounds really simple but but people
don't do it people just don't do it
yeah you know in general that in you
know lots of companies that I visited or
like you said like smaller startups that
I thought I helped out with in an
advisory role they just don't do these
things and you know if you think about
the number of projects that fail in
business and then the amount of research
or forethought that goes into them you
know in general that that's way way off
right and and you know to go back to
probability if there's even an even even
if you think there's a 90% chance of
something succeeding and a 10% chance of
failing well then it's worth it to spend
ten percent of the time ahead of time to
see if it's going to work and so what
that means is if you're starting a
10-week project you spend a week to
research it right and and people don't
do that right people not at all spend
people spent two hours thinking about it
and then go that'd be a great idea then
they and they hop off and do it for 10
weeks
right and just depend on perspective
that means if it's a ten year project it
could take that you could justify a year
yeah in doing due diligence which is
totally entirely not the case obviously
in the vast majority of instances yeah
or budget right if it's if it's a
hundred million dollar project you
should spend 10 million dollars just
researching it
if you think there's a 10% chance it's
gonna fail if right and and more than
more than 10% of projects actually fail
right so if you think there's a 25%
chance that it that it fails you spend
25 million dollars researching a 100
million dollar project this is assuming
that you're gonna take the the research
project is going to take the odds of
success to a hundred percent but still
it's it's you know and and you know it's
not a perfect rule that nobody knows
these exact numbers but certainly the
amount of forethought or research that's
done in general is like way way way
under you know what even a ballpark
estimate would say that the amount of
forethought should go into it do you uh
do you do you hire people who have
pre-existing excel experience I do not
for instance I mean I I can read an
Excel document but if I have to create
macros and so on I couldn't create an
Excel spreadsheet that functions to save
my life how would you how would you
train how do you train someone to do you
do it all internally do you have a
certain course you recommend anything
like that yeah we do it all internally
and then again like macros there are
just way way ahead of anything we're
doing right just getting a standard
excel sheet working just you know just
it's call it ten rows and and ten
columns yeah is fine and then and right
and you can build up from there as you
learn more and you get more comfortable
but you know again you know this going
back to the attitude again saying like I
can't do macros and I can't do like
vlookups and and I can't do pivot tables
I can't do those either but you know but
basic Excel is none of that basic excel
is I have you know it's just that it's I
have ten door manufacturers or whatever
100 door manufacturers are making ten
doors and you multiply those two cells
together and you get a thousand and
that's how you should start right you
should start with just the one row so
like let's start with just the one row
of like I'm gonna make a thousand doors
and so it's just like literally one cell
that's as a thousand and then you say
okay well what's the math behind that
and so then you say okay well I need a
hundred manufacturers that are each
gonna make ten doors so you make two new
cells and you say you know you put a
hundred in one cell and ten in the other
cell and then the third cell that used
to just say a thousand is
now you change that to be the product of
those other two cells mm-hmm right so
you say that that third cell equals the
first cell times the second cell right
and then and so now if you change the
numbers in the you know in the number of
door manufactures you have the thousand
will automatically shift right and then
and then you say okay well how many why
do I have this many door manufactures
why do I think I have a hundred door
manufacturers and it's like oh because
I'm gonna hire 50 this month and 50 next
month and so right so now that hundred
instead of just being a hundred is is
the sum of two other cells that each say
fifty mm-hmm right and so you just you
just work backwards from there you just
take each cell and break it down into
its subcomponents mm-hmm and pretty soon
you have a working Excel document and it
doesn't need to be more complex than
that and that's right and that's a great
start and you'll do that for a while and
then you'll be comfortable with that
then you'll be like what is it what is
this pivot table nonsense that
everyone's talking about and is it
actually useful and then you'll go into
pivot tables and rape it but nobody that
you know nobody in the history of Excel
no matter what kind of computer genius
they were like started day one and was
like how do I make macros work how do I
make pivot tables work right they all
started this way it's just the excel and
you know it's like the big sort of
secret of mathematicians in general is
that you know everybody started from one
plus one equals two and built their way
up and it's just the you know it's just
each step is not a big step once you
understand the previous step mm-hmm
yeah there's a gentleman and believe his
name is Keith Devlin out of Stanford
who's very good at at speaking to this
topic and I always find myself sort of
nodding and agreeing with him after
every essay I read or interview I hear
and then once I once I sort of look at
the possibility of delving into numbers
and I get cold sweats which I think it
over let me let me change gears just a
little bit and ask sort of fill in the
picture of who Nick Ganju is and I and
the first is do you have a a favorite
book or a book that you've given most as
a gift yeah I mean it depends in which
context so you kind of you could give a
couple sure sure
so in it for my software engineers I
love a book called don't make me think
which is a book about usability and
making making software and user
interfaces that that are friendly to
people and often you see these software
engineers where they kind of scoff and
everyone's you know encountered this guy
it's an IT guy or a software engineer
that's scoffs at the novice user right
they say haha this guy doesn't know how
to use this thing like this guy doesn't
know how to use Photoshop you know he's
a dumb or he doesn't know how to make
his network he doesn't know how to
connect his his computer the network and
and he's so dumb and right that attitude
is something that needs to vanish and if
you look at successful companies like
Apple where you know things just work
you know none of the engineers have that
attitude right they have the attitude of
manoa bad software company has the
attitude of if somebody doesn't know how
to use something it's their fault
because that user is dumb and then if
and a good software company is the
attitude of if they don't know how to
use something it's our fault because we
did not make the software intuitive
enough right and and we didn't make it
simple enough for for people to use and
you see Apple as a shining example of
that where they they really go out of
their way and do extra work you know the
engineers do immense amounts of extra
work to make it easy and some simple for
the user and they're rewarded in the
market and that you know and so the book
that I love which which helps reinforce
that sort of culture you know that
user-friendly culture here at ZocDoc
there's a book called don't make me
think which is a book on usability and
it and it you know it's sort of a simple
book it's like 100 250 pages lots of you
know illustrations about like you know
good user interface isn't bad you're bad
user interfaces and it's so it's kind of
an easy read but it is a treatise on on
why we should make usable interfaces and
not not just how we should make them
like you know what what sort of you know
user interface sort of patterns work or
don't work but also why we should do
that right and right and and this is the
reason right like I mean think about
ZocDoc
right if if you go to the home page you
know people are discovering us for the
first time they go to the home page and
if it's if it's complicated there's
going to
right right and and if it's simple
they're gonna stay in and book an
appointment and so you know it's all
very well a nice of us to scoff about
you know haha that user didn't know how
to use our homepage and we can be
haughty and scuff about it but then we
just didn't get that appointment right
it's our it's our job to get people to
book appointments and so right there's
no there's no room for being haughty
about that like we need to make it
accessible to everybody yeah as a side
note the best just to choose something
that that people are also often afraid
of learning languages the best language
teacher one of the best language
teachers I've ever encountered was of
the his name is Michelle Thomas amazing
guy if you can get the original
recordings of the classes that he did
they're just amazing and and what he
would say to the students right off the
bat was don't worry don't be nervous
don't try hard because if you if you
don't learn it's Myra it's my fault not
yours it's the job of the teacher to
make sure that you learn so he took the
exact same approach with language
learning and unburdened the student to
make it the responsibility of the
teacher to make it easy which is I think
partially why he was so spectacular Lee
successful so now it just goes to show
and he could get people up to basic
speaking in all the romance languages in
about eight hours of class times really
amazing so what other what other books
outside of outside of don't make me
think do you do give most as a gift or
recommend most and then you know how to
measure anything which is what we talked
about before which is which is about you
know being outcome based and being you
know getting these measurable outcomes
saying I'm gonna lose 10 pounds as
opposed to just saying I'm gonna try to
lose weight is you know and this this is
a great book because you know people
often complain that they can't measure
something right like I mean how many
people like our site like if people do
people really like our website well how
do you measure that
well it's measurable right you can do a
survey you can ask people you can you
can just look at conversion rate so how
many people actually do something on
your website as opposed to just look at
it and run away and so this book is as
you know I found is quite informative on
to how to think about
you know measuring things that you might
have thought were intangible
historically and it also goes into these
kind of ideas about why it's valuable to
measure something so going back to what
I was saying about you know if there's a
10% chance of something failing well
then you should spend 10% of your time
like before doing it you know deciding
if it's gonna fail or not and and so
really getting that disciplined about
about doing you know doing enough
forethought and like sort of reflection
upfront there's another big sort of you
know theme of this book I thought the
confidence interval aspect was really
fascinating as well not something that
I've thought enough about yeah and just
you know if you're 90% confident that
something is going to happen or that
something is correct what does that
actually mean you know people throw that
around like house are you I'm 75%
certain like how did I how should that
be reflected in your actions and
preparation and so on right right right
yeah I thought was really really
fascinating do you have a what is your
favorite documentary or movie or
favorites and these don't have to be
highbrow it could be Legally Blonde I
really like Forrest Gump a lot I don't
know that's like a common one or a
cheesy one what do you like well it's
you know it's just like yeah in the
beginning I mean it's sort of obvious
symbolism but in the beginning there's
like a feather floating around the end
there's a feather floating around and
he's sort of you know he kind of floats
around right like he kind of he kind of
yeah I forgot the exact story but like
yeah I think he's like running oh I know
he's like there's a football field and
he kind of runs through it because he's
running he's fleeing from something yeah
he runs faster than everybody so then
they kind of like oh my god we got to
get that guy to play football and then
he plays football and then he goes to
college because he plays football at the
end of college like some army recruiter
just hands him a flier just at random
and says like you should join the army
he's like ok I'll join the army and so
he's just kind of floating around on the
wind there and I think it's it's a good
sort of lesson where you know where you
don't take yourself too seriously right
like it's like you're going to just like
things are gonna happen
and the more you stress out about like
life is not going exactly the way I
planned rather the more unhappy you're
gonna make yourself which is not to say
you shouldn't try to do things but you
know you should certainly try to shake
your life and and all this but but you
know don't don't take it too seriously
or don't don't stress out too much when
things don't go exactly how you planned
so how I would love to hear maybe a
concrete example from your life because
from all outward indications I mean
you've done exceptionally well with
ZocDoc and and elsewhere how do you
choose how much to plan versus I sort of
allow to to to bend to serendipity right
because you you do a bunch of other
things we haven't gotten into yet but
yeah the music you know take very very
seriously yeah we're going to talk about
ping pong now that you mentioned Forrest
Gump but like well let's use like let's
use ping pong as an example let's tell
her tell well maybe you can explain
the ping pong the the ping pong
phenomenon and what your experience of
ping pong and just sure you know this
goes back to what you're saying about
you know older people wanting to learn
something you know people I play guitar
and people say well I wish i had started
guitar when I was a kid so I could play
and I said well I started when I was 28
and so you know still young but not you
know I wasn't like a 10 year old and and
ping pong I learned when I was when I
was 36 and I'm 38 now and I thought that
would be it's another interesting thing
it's really I think people limit
themselves as to they think they can
learn or it's almost like an excuse to
not have to try to learn something right
right I'm 36 like I can't learn a ping
pong now I'm too old and it's just it
kind of makes it easy to say it's it's
easy to not try to double down and
actually learn something because you can
just kind of cast it off and say oh I'm
too old to learn new things right but
the story of the ping pong was that we
got we purchased two or three ping pong
tables from my office two years ago and
and I was the worst player I had never
played
in my life I'd played like five times in
my whole life and and I was the worst
player out of everybody and and
everybody was laughing and they were
like hahaha
because you know it's always fun to like
just screw the boss right so the boss
talks of ping pong haha we're all
beating the boss ping pumps and so I got
I got you know I got I got motivated
let's say I got motivates a good
attitude you know and I threw down the
gauntlet and I said okay I'm gonna be
everybody here I'm gonna beat every at
this company in 30 days okay so you
proclaimed this this was like right
proclaimed it out loud and and you know
and I photoshopped like the the hiya you
know the hilum there's a Highlander I
don't know if you remember that movie
the files there and be only one like yes
so like you know there's a sort like
they're he's like there's a photo of him
with the sword in the air and the
lightning is striking the sword and I
replaced the sword of the ping-pong
paddle and lightning striking the
ping-pong paddle and I wrote there could
be only one and but you know but I
practiced and practiced and in in 30
days I had beaten all but two people at
the company and then and then and you
know because this is like the long tail
of right like at the end of the bell
curve who's gonna be people are
exceptionally good but and getting
Manthey again I know but no it's just
like I mean it's like you know Facebook
and Peter teals portfolio right there's
just sort of like a power-law yeah yeah
exactly
last two people are gonna be monsters
yeah yeah yeah and so but then in
another three days I beat those two
people and so I said in 30 days I'll
beat everybody but in 60 days I beat
everybody but two people in 30 days and
then 60 days I beat everybody how did
you how did you go about learning it
like when you sat down you're like okay
now I run the risk of humiliating myself
if I don't make this happen
yeah what was your when you sat down to
like plan it out how did you do it yeah
so first of all I don't think like
that's an interesting sort of way to put
it it never occurred to me to say like
oh I'm humiliating myself I didn't do
this and maybe that's like a sort of
mentality that's you know maybe that's
like illustrative of the mental
right I wasn't it until you said that
now like two years later it never
crossed my mind that like the
humiliation of defeat or how humiliating
that would be and so you know maybe you
know it's just it it's more constructive
to just think about like to focus on the
positive of when you're gonna win and
not and not like fret about the downside
so what do you loading over the other
the employees in company yes how did you
sit down to do to plan it out or what
okay so the method because I actually
want to get good at ping pong so I'm
sure sure sure so the first thing was
and by far the most important thing was
I went to the ping pong like Slyke
parlor by my house and took lessons and
so right and that was and then when I at
the end when so I taking lessons once a
week from there and I you know and that
of course just just catapulted me in my
skill level but and what would happen
was at the third or fourth week one of
my co-workers came into that ping pong
parlor and saw me Sami taking lessons
and spilled to the entire company that I
had been taking lessons and which I
thought was another interesting sort of
you know reflection on life which is you
know people are like oh you didn't say
you were gonna do that thing right and I
was like I didn't say what I was gonna
do or what I wasn't gonna do is just
gonna beat everybody and you know when
we started sock-doc people said the same
thing right people said oh you'll never
get like you know there's there's
practice management software that exists
out there and they said you know you'll
never be able to integrate to these
third-party practice management systems
because they're too antiquated and right
that they're not going to release a new
version and someone some of the
companies are you know they're not even
developing those things anymore and we
went in you know we just went in reverse
engineer some of the existing ones just
by literally like getting copies of the
software and and deconstructing the file
structure and and really reverse
engineering it
here we got it working and all of a
sudden you know ZocDoc started working
the you know the all these all these
antiquated software's were effectively
communicating with us and then those
naysayers are like oh you didn't say you
were gonna do that right like we thought
you had to strike up partnerships with
all these like software companies you
didn't say you were just gonna get the
software in reverse-engineer it and it's
like well I didn't say I was or I wasn't
but it's like you know if you're
thinking so inside the box and then when
somebody thinks outside the box and get
something done he did he you know you
should learn from me you should be like
oh that's slick you shouldn't be like oh
I I you didn't say you were gonna do
that that's not fair
yeah it's not and you know that's
another sort of illustration of like I'd
say you know positive attitudes versus
negative attitudes so I took these
lessons so I took these ping pong
lessons and then they go you didn't say
you're gonna do that and then they
started saying only you can afford
lessons the guy the guy that came and
found me in the ping pong place was like
he he ran into me at the bar of there's
there's a bar in this ping pong parlor
and he said yeah not everyone can afford
the lessons and I was like he's like I
was like how much did you spend on these
drinks and he had bought a round of
drinks for four or five of his friends
and he was like this is $40 and I was
like the the ping pong lesson I just
took this $35 and I'm not drinking and I
haven't bought any drinks so I'm gonna
come out of this ping pong you know
place spending less than you have but
you know so the first thing I did was
that and and started with proper form
and then and then practiced a lot when
when people weren't around how did you
practice when people weren't around so
there's and water I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna cheat here I guess what are
some of the most common mistakes that
people make playing ping pong just like
the randos who like have a couple beers
and grab a ping pong table like what
when you watch it what makes you cringe
really like off they only knew the
basics they should do this not do that
yeah yeah number one is is the is the
grip so a lot of people just hold it
atrociously just hold the ping pong
paddle and you know whatever way the
first your first inclined to do it and
you know the general way there's a
couple like schools of hold of holding
it but the general you're supposed to do
it is it's called a handshake and so you
sort of extend your hand like you
having a hand [ __ ] you know here about
to shake somebody's hand and then you
you put the handle in that way sort of
hard to explain it I think I get it so
your your your four fingers not your
thumb then or extended kind of
diagonally across the back the flat
portion as opposed to the handle of one
of the paddles yeah I mean you don't
want to cover a large portion of the
paddle with your hand because on your
backhand will just let your fingers
right but yeah that's essentially the
right idea okay people have though the
handshake yeah handshake method and then
in the handshake grip and then the the
other thing is people just don't have
any conception of how big a big how big
a role spin is in the game hmm
and so it's a it's a very light ball and
spin has immense effect on the ball and
so you normal like looping forehand is
supposed to have a lot of topspin on it
and so every ball should have spin on it
and you know depending on what you're
trying to do if you're trying to slice
it if you're trying to side spin if
you're trying to topspin if you're just
hitting it flat then you're sort of
forsaking an opportunity to do something
you know tricky with it that that would
that would screw up your opponent and so
you know learning how to hit the ball
with spin is I'd say the second biggest
thing cool what what do you've any
morning or evening rituals like what is
the first hour of your day look like
it's an interesting question uh I mean I
suppose I don't really have any rituals
I just get up and get ready and coming
to work you know I think that you do
brush your teeth too every morning I do
brush my teeth the other days I remember
I know I think that I'm very fortunate
in that every day has a different set of
challenges and like you know I kind of
have the whole the whole company is as
part of you know the stuff that I'm
concerned with so let me let me rephrase
them cuz I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
push a little I bet you do have patterns
at least and whether it's weekly or
daily and I'm just curious what of those
patterns contribute to your
sort of uh effectiveness or you know I
just output or lower your stress right I
mean so you you know music is part of
your life but are there are there things
you do say on a weekly basis like one
day a week or twice a week or whatever
it might be that you think allow you to
be a high functioning person without
your sort of having to be put in a
mental institution every once in a while
to de-stress yeah certainly uh you know
I guess I don't really I've never really
thought about it in those terms I don't
may be that I'm not like maybe not
self-aware that like today I need to you
know today I should do something that
de-stress because my stress levels are
are high and and certainly I do get you
know to you know there are certainly are
days when stress levels are high and I
don't think I am self-aware enough to
like to have like okay today I should
meditate or whatever but you know I
certainly read a lot you know I I think
I tried to like rid myself of of
cognitive biases yes something that is
extremely nerdy thing to say you yeah
can you explain to people for those
people who may not be familiar what that
means yeah sure so or give an example
yeah yeah yeah so there's there's a huge
slew of you know what a psychologist
would call cognitive biases that humans
have and what they are are things that
make you know a human for whatever
reason like you know evolutionary reason
it makes them averse to something that
they shouldn't be averse to or it like
irrationally evaluate things and so I'll
give you an example we can go back to
gambling again
you know let's use the same example so
like if we if it was $10 you know if if
we rolled a die and each time we lost
each time I was one through five you
lost $1 and if it was 61 you know $10
then you would play that game right
because over time you would be positive
but if each if each time zooming I have
the bankroll yeah correct yeah assuming
you have the bankroll but let's say each
time that you rolled that die instead of
instead of each role losing $1 it 135
losing $1 and 6 gaining $10 let's say
they each of one through five you lost
$10,000 and then and then with a six you
won $100,000 mm-hmm
now would you play that game so it you
know it turns out that most people
wouldn't play that game even though the
numbers are the same because the fear of
losing that much money is is right it
sort of insurmountable and so people
have these even though you should play
that game right and a large business
would play that game and even a rational
actor would play that game and so people
have so that's a cognitive bias called
loss aversion right like losing $100 you
feel more bad for losing $100 then you
feel good when you win $100 right yeah
the second cost fallacy close close
cousin right so you've people yeah
yeah hold on to my investment just
because they right it's gone down a
certain amount yeah yeah yeah my
favorite story of sunk cost is is
there's this tennis this Tennis Club
where where you can rent where the
outdoor courts are free but the indoor
courts you have to rent and you have to
rent them ahead of time you have to rent
them like three weeks ahead of time you
just pay like 50 bucks for for the court
for an hour or whatever and and this is
a real case I forgot where it was but in
like March or April you know you and the
other courts are generally considered to
be far more pleasurable because you're
outside and it's warm and whatever sunny
and the indoor courts are you know it's
uncomfortable like white lights or
whatever yeah and so what happens is in
April it'll be a beautiful sunny day and
and the people will be playing on the
indoor courts and the outdoor courts are
empty and you say well why are you
playing on the indoor court you should
go play outside and they're like well
we've already paid for the indoor court
right we paid for it last week so now
we're gonna go to the indoor court we're
gonna play you like put the outdoor
court is far nicer and it's empty why
don't you go play there right and they
go well no because we've paid for this
one and so it's not it's a sunk cost
fallacy right and it's it's a this is a
cognitive bias right you should do the
thing that is most like you know it you
should play tennis on the most
pleasurable courts then it doesn't
matter if you paid 50 bucks oh we could
go for the less
court if the nicer court is open right
now you should play in a nice report so
I should mention for folks as as
imperfect as Wikipedia might be there if
you search list of cognitive biases yeah
don't don't search cognitive bias search
list of cognitive biases there's a long
list of these types of cognitive biases
and they're also a lot of books that
explore this like think twice but the
there's sort of two approaches here
right so there are two ways that you can
minimize the damage of cognitive biases
or extract value from them right the
first is correcting those cognitive
biases or at least becoming aware of
them the second is harnessing your
inherent cognitive biases for something
positive rights for instance there are
cases where experiments have been done
with say gym memberships and so having
someone pay on a monthly basis for gym
membership is not nearly as effective as
say having them overpay in advance and
then giving them a refund of X amount
for for each Y number of times they go
to the gym and sort of harnessing that
type of prepayment and loss aversion and
some can cost to to incentivize somebody
to do something positive they wouldn't
otherwise do so it's anyway this is also
something that I like to nerd out about
so yeah yeah what does what's a
behavioral what's a cognitive bias that
you that you overcame or something that
you're currently working on anything in
particular yeah sure I mean I think all
of these things were things that all
these things are things that are very
innate in everybody and so I think you
know I at some point I did have sunk
cost fallacy at some point I did have
loss aversion and these kind of things
let me see what's a big one that I think
another big one that everyone has is
anchoring and I certainly had that
before which is you know in a
negotiation where when it's not clear
like what the price for something should
be you should you should just throw out
a huge number like like okay like what
you said like if you wanted me to be if
you wanted me to be your your mentor
or right and so what should an hourly
rate be between you and me like I have
like I have no idea like I don't I've
never taught like you know for for you
know for a living and so we'd have no
idea you and I so in that silent moment
when when you and I are like what do you
think the price should be I'm gonna
blurt out $1,000 an hour that's what I'm
gonna say right and it's not because I
think I deserve that it's because now
I've anchored the conversation saying a
huge number like that has like blown
away you're like you know it's destroyed
like your brain I've just destroyed your
brain and so right and so now when we
settle on it on a final number it's
going to be much higher than it would
have been otherwise and that that's just
a cognitive bias and I and now like like
you said you use these to your advantage
this is a situation which I can use that
to my advantage so right the final
especially because especially because I
suck at math on top of that yeah yeah
yeah so right where's the final you know
if I hadn't done that the final price
might have been twenty-five dollars an
hour and since I threw out that huge
number it's like screwed up your brain
now and and the final prices it's
instead going to be $40 an hour because
because anchoring thing and so and so
that that's a great one for all you
listeners out there let's go into
negotiation go try to try this try this
out it only works when there's a not not
a preset sort of unspoiled Toyota right
and how much should it be and like you
know a ballpark should be five grand I
can't be like 100 grand just sounds
stupid
and like rude right to be yeah so so it
only works really when when there's not
a good expectation from either party
that it that is a good point that then
that negotiating is a fantastic way
that's probably the most systematic way
that I've tried to address my own
self-defeating instincts would be
another way to look at biases right so
the secrets of power negotiating is a
great book the audio is even better
getting past no I think is a fantastic
book better than getting to yes do you
have any have you
read any particular books on negotiating
or actually yeah the first book that
came to mind for me was getting to you
so I had reigned yes okay what I love I
love getting to yes and I love you know
a lot of important things that people
misunderstand and if just further that
with the example I just said was that
not not all negotiation is a zero-sum
game yep
I think getting to yes is a great it was
a great you know exposition of that yep
yeah no it's it's I think you'd enjoy
getting past no it was actually written
after getting to yes by one of the
co-authors of getting getting to yes
what uh when you think of the word
successful or hear the word successful
who's the first person that comes to
mind and why I think I'd say Bill Gates
maybe that's a cliche like sort of
obvious answer but you know depends it
depends on the reasons you gave I guess
he's in tack right he is slash was a
computer nerd I'm a computer nerd you
know he built the immense and you know
one of the greatest software companies
greatest technology companies ever and
something that I aspire to do and then
not you know not only that but then you
know then you know sort of the second
chapter of his life he's now gone and
done all this great philanthropy and
it's something that it you know I would
I would love to follow in his footsteps
on that when you know retirement time
comes for me is to go in and give back
and and do these philanthropic efforts
uh if you were to follow Bill Gates path
in a lot of those respects they just
mentioned what are the things about Bill
Gates it if you could opt out of
emulating you would opt out of I don't
know I guess it is a tough one
I guess he you could see like you know I
guess he was very rough on his own
employees and within within Microsoft
and I think that at a younger age I was
I was also very you know very abrupt and
sort of you know uh you know fit
susceptible to like bouts of you know
anger
whatever and I think I've come a long
way at this company to to be a lot nicer
and write it as like I had a couple
startups in my 20s and I think I was
very sort of mercurial at and those in
those startups but by the time I had
started ZocDoc and sort of ironed all
that out and it's much better to manage
be a nice person when you're managing I
like mercurial that's a good adjective I
was it makes me think of a comedian
named Jim Gaffigan now if you've ever
heard of him but yeah he said he said
yeah you know I wish I were I think he I
think he said at some point paraphrasing
was like yeah you know if you're a latin
guy woman and you're really angry people
say wow it's just that Latin temper and
he's like but if I behave that way
people just say wow that guy is a dick
but mercurial I like that choice it's
just my indian passion coming I don't
know what that yeah I can't pull off
Scandinavian passion this doesn't
doesn't doesn't usually get accepted the
I so on the flip side what's the first
face that comes to mind when you think
punchable oh Jesus I don't know I can't
I don't know doesn't be a real person
I'll give you I'll give you an out maybe
the Jersey Shore people right you know
the sort of people that are you know
famous for being famous yeah like not
the people that are you know have
actually contributed built stuff yeah
build stuff yeah what's the what are the
most frequently played albums or artists
on your iPhone or computer well I love
the Beatles a lot mm-hm and I think that
the more the more I listen to them the
more complexity and and sort of stuff
you discover as you listen to their
stuff over and over which is great right
a lot of a lot of pop songs are just
really simple and the first time you
hear it you've heard everything there is
to hear but you know and the Beatles
early stuff was like that like it was
really simple and kind of
about like chasing girls and stuff and
then later on they they got really
really sophisticated and and you know
there's a lot of lovely complexity to
the music and as you know I'm a big you
know I play music myself and I
understand quite a bit about music
theory which is you know again getting
sort of mathematical but really
understanding why things sound good and
why this chord sounds great here and
this kind of stuff is all once again
math and not complicated math simple
math but but I love music theory and you
know those guys were the kings of that
what what would be two or three tracks
that you would suggest people listen to
to explore that let me see if you find a
limit let me think
I like across the universe a lot so if
you find like you can just you can even
see like which once you understand music
theory you can even see like which ones
were written by whom and so you can see
like Paul McCartney always plays this he
always puts the four minor in it in his
in his songs and that's a sort of a
music theory term but he's a big fan of
putting the four minor in in his writing
and so you can when you hear you know
for minor come up you're like I bet this
one was written by McCartney and then
you go look at interests in it and so I
like across the universe which does have
a four minor in it
I like I like something that's that once
but I think it's by George Harrison and
let me see what are some other good ones
certainly like the more psychedelic ones
like Lucy in the Sky with Diamonds is
great I am The Walrus is great and yeah
there's really no end to the to the list
yeah if you had a thousand people
non-musicians people who listen to music
but have never played an instrument and
you wanted to get them hooked on
learning more about music and
potentially playing music yeah what
would you have them read watch listen
by when
it's an instrument otherwise I mean you
you or you are in large part responsible
for getting me interested in hand
drumming right but I'm not sure if
that's the best gateway drug with music
but what would you what would you have
them listen to or buy or play with or do
if you had a thousand people and you'd
like a million dollars on the line I'm
not sure what the minimal threshold is
for you to to make it now I do a
business case and say I can train this
make you know yeah I think that probably
the guitar is the easiest because
interesting I wouldn't have guessed that
why yeah because I think well for a
couple reasons it's not it's probably
not the easiest to to play in terms of
like I mean you know it's kind of hard
to hold a chord and obviously the piano
you could just plunk the keys but but
the second you get over the hump of
learning three or four chords on guitar
you're off to the races right because
you can learn you can play so many pop
songs with just three or four chords on
guitar and so within a few weeks you can
already start playing you know you know
simple songs and and then like twist and
shout for examples to go back to the
Beatles is just three chords three easy
chords and so you can play twist and
shout and you know in a week or two
really well and then and then what you
do is as you learn each new song pick a
song with one extra chord in it
right so so this next song has the same
three chords this twist and shout but
one minor chord in it and so now right
so now you're learning that new song
you're leveraging right 75% you already
know because it's the other three chords
and you're only picking up one new chord
and so then as as you play you know as
you pick new songs just add one new
chord each time on your repertoire girls
of songs you know and the repertoire of
chords you know also grows and it makes
write and so it's really easy to get
into that groove where it's fun to play
because you're playing songs that
everybody likes and it doesn't feel like
you know work or rehearsal or practice
it's just you know each one I just have
to practice one new chord and over time
you know over the course of a year
you'll learn a ton of a ton of songs
that the a couple of resources promote
for folks potentially one is just
googling axis of awesome whoo I think it
does an amazing example
showing with three or four chords how
you can play almost every pop song
you've ever heard yeah that chord
progression is called one five six four
mm-hmm and there you go that people
could just google that coordination one
five six four that's in the music theory
notation would be one five six four and
then and they play like a hundred
different songs and it's really
hilarious yeah they're they're amazing
are there any for someone to add one
quart at a time without having to
manually figure it out themselves and
kind of reinvent the wheel is there any
particular approach that you would
suggest and doing that any any way that
you would google for that to figure it
out or a youtube approach or teachers i
mean yeah there's there's a I mean
there's a extreme wealth of online of
you know online diagrams and and YouTube
videos about how to do these things so
you know we do search for to whittle it
down I think it's a paradox of choice
challenge for a lot of people yeah I
don't know really I guess it's not like
for the basic chords it's it's really
like any anything will do
you know for example a a D major chord
it's just you know it's three of your
fingers your index middle and fourth
finger and then you have to put them on
the bottom three strings of the of the
guitar on the second fret third fret and
2nd fret and so you just have to you
know it's just that right it's not more
complicated than that there's no like
specific you know form that you have to
do when you approach the guitar whatever
you just got to slam your three fingers
down on those three frets on those three
strings and you'll play a D chord and so
at that level you know you just need to
know which fingers to put on which
strings where and it's not you know it's
not an intense sort of yeah you know
form exercise or anything cool alright
last question for now in this
installment if you could give your 20
year old self advice at this point in
retrospect what would it be and it
doesn't have to be one thing oh man
we're just 20 year olds in general could
be you yourself but it could be in
general sure I mean I guess it would go
back to these
so I'd say certainly when you're young
do the things do the entrepreneurial
things
because those are the things that will
get you right you'll learn the most by
far and so I did like I said I did two
startups in my twenties and they were
you know that neither one was a great
hit
but but the amount I learned in you know
one year of doing a startup was like
doing you know was like seven years of
working at a at a you know at a big
company and so you know when you're
young and you know you just finish
college or whatever and you've got this
you know you've got this freedom and
you're not encumbered with you know you
know with the spouse and kids that you
have to that you have to pay for and you
can live on ramen noodles and all this
stuff that's the time to go and take
this entrepreneurial risk because you
even if everything you do is a complete
flop you know if you spend five years
doing it you will have learned like 35
years worth of you know career
progression and life skills in those
five years of just risking and failing
and risking and failing so even if it's
total flop they the person that you come
out at the end of it as is far ahead of
if you just gone and worked at a big
company so on that on that point I lied
about the last question this is more for
for people who are graduating now or
considering a a shift a career change
I'm not sure if this is age dependent
but let's just say for the sake of
argument that they're they're single or
they just have a very low burn rate what
would how would you suggest people
choose their first gig or their next gig
I know it's a highly personal thing but
let's let's just say people graduating
college in the near future for the sake
of simplicity yeah I mean it's just like
figure out a market need like anything
that you have in your day-to-day world
you know that that sucks like what is
you know is it hard to find parking or
can you you know there's a movie theater
dirty or whatever and and just try to
solve that problem and you know I think
that's that's a great way to get started
and it you know you'll learn a lot
you'll do something you know you'll just
create a website where it's like you
chose you like which movie theaters are
dirty and you'll realize wow I can't
like there's no revenue for
this website like I can't I can't make
any money telling people what movie
theaters are dirty but then that's
learning by itself right and and you
know and you come away from that and
you're like okay I need to think about
you know things with actual revenue
opportunities and you'll do that
iterative process and you'll you know
you'll flop a bunch but that's fine like
that's the learning process and you know
it's the school of hard knocks and
you're gonna learn a ton just doing that
kind of stuff awesome
well Nick I think this is this is a
great place to stop for now I'm sure
we'll have a round two in person with so
yeah I wouldn't someone but that I was a
lot of fun a lot of fun where can people
learn more about you or ZocDoc where
would you like people to check uh check
what ya do out certainly you know I'm on
the about Us page of ZocDoc so but you
know more importantly if you know if you
need a doctor it really is the best
place to find a doctor so doc dog zo
CDOC calm for myself I don't I don't
have any I don't have any about you know
like I don't have a shrine to me on the
web anywhere so I've got a LinkedIn page
you can find me on the LinkedIn page I
suppose but uh but you know ZocDoc is my
is my pride and joy so go there awesome
alright well I'm going to I'm gonna I'm
gonna cut my teeth on some ping pong and
we may have may have to have a showdown
next time we balls of fury style
awesome man well thanks very much and I
will talk to you soon
awesome thanks a lot everybody
this episode of the tim ferriss show is
brought to you by 99 designs and
ex-officio 99 designs is the world's
largest online marketplace of graphic
designers and I have used 99 designs for
years including to get cover concepts
for the 4-hour body which went on to
become number one New York Times number
one Wall Street Journal it was a huge
hit and here's how it works
and you can check everything out
including some of my competitions you
can see these book covers and so on
99designs comm forward slash Tim whether
you need a logo car app a web design an
app a thumbnail a t-shirt whatever you
go to 99 designs com you describe your
project and then within a week or less
you have tons of designers around the
world who compete for your business and
submit different ideas and designs and
drafts you have an original design that
you love or you pay nothing it is
fantastic I have used it I have
mentioned it before including in the
4-hour workweek as a resource check it
out 99 designs com forward slash Tim and
if you use that link you'll be able to
see what I've done on the platform you
will also get $99 as an upgrade for free
which will get you more designs more
submissions so check it out
ex-officio boy where do I begin I have a
long history with ex-officio ex-officio
makes clothing and as far back as 2007
2008 I had a hit video that went viral
called how to travel the world with 10
pounds or less and I talked about
ex-officio underwear ex-officio
underwear is lightweight ultra
lightweight quick drying and
antimicrobial why is this important well
I've gone through 20 plus countries with
two pairs of underwear before both from
ex-officio and I'm not alone in this
this might sound crazy but a lot of
executives for instance will take this
underwear they'll wash it in the sink or
somewhere else roll it up in a towel
like a burrito step on it and a few
hours later they are completely dry
completely clean you don't have to just
have to and yes they have to be
comfortable for all-day wear but check
out their clothing as well as their
underwear you can go to ex-officio com
forward slash Tim that's X DX o FF IC
ioad
come forward / Tim and you can see this
video which has a bunch of other packing
tips but this underwear this clothing is
not just for the gents ladies you have
choices - and they really have an
incredible collection of high quality
products that I've used for almost 10
years now so check them out
ex-officio comm forward slash Tim and
until next time thank you for listening